The thing to remember about photogrammetry is that not all objects scan well. This is especially true with objects that have reflective or transparent surfaces.
Photogrammetry software work by finding feature points that are common between pictures taken at various angles.
If these common points change between one picture and the next, then the process fails.
This inevitably happens when dealing with reflective and or transparent surfaces.
It also happens when surfaces are very dark, plain colored or otherwise devoid of feature points.
There are workarounds that result with varying degrees of success.
One common method is to coat the object with a layer of thin powder, such as chalk spray or dry shampoo.
While these methods may give reasonable results, they can also be messy and a bit hard to clean.
There are also some commercial products that are known to work well, as they are engineered for that purpose.
They are also easier to clean. In fact, the substance powdery surface disappears by itself a couple of hours after application.
Another method of reducing reflections, glare and even shadows is cross-polarization.
This involves using polarized lenses on both your light and your camera, adding a bit of specialized hardware to your budget.
By using two polarized lenses and rotating them against each other, you significantly reduce artifacts that can make your scan fail.
Ideally, you would use a ring flash for this process, coupled with a polarized lens.
These ring flashes are typically powerful enough to mitigate the effect of direct sunlight, making them useful for external shots.
They would remove all instances of natural shadows, giving you true albedo textures in the process.
You would also need a polarized filter for your camera.
Fortunately, polarized DSLR camera filters are quite common in photography and easy to come by.
Ultimately, when you have all your hardware in place and after you've taken pictures, you still need to process those.
There are various solutions out there, some are free, others are commercial.
Here we'll concentrate on Epic Games' own photogrammetry solutions and in particular the desktop app known as RealityCapture.
But in the next video, I will discuss photogrammetry on smartphones, so you are at least familiar with that process and options.